now streaming live on custom live
streaming service
you're jen you're muted it takes just a
[Music]
okay let the record show that we're
starting three minutes late but it
wasn't my fault
um good morning
everyone i miss you more than you can
imagine
[Music]
and i'd like to call
the judiciary committee to order
as chair of the judiciary committee i
find that due to the state of emergency
department of the governor as a result
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 20 2004
this public body is authorized
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order however
in accordance with the emergency order i
am confirming
that we are providing public access to
the meeting by telephone with additional
access possibilities by video or
other electronic means we are utilizing
zoom
for this electronic meeting all members
of the committee and select staff have
the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by clicking on the following website
address https
colon slash slash www
dot zoom dot u s slash i slash
nine four two six one four
one one five nine nine or dialing one of
1-312-626-6799-1929-205-6099
b providing public notice of the
necessary information for accessing the
meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting
including how to access access the
meeting using
zoom or telephonically this information
is printed in the house calendar
c providing a mechanism for the public
to alert the public body during the
meeting if there are problems with
access
if anyone has a problem please call 603
271 3600
or email hcs at
leg dot state dot nh
d adjourning the meeting if the public
is unable to accept
access the meeting in the event the
public is unable to
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff that are on the
meeting assisting us jennifer four is
the meeting host additional staff
sort of providing uh additional staff
providing supporter christina
dyer and paul greenland this is
a work session on the bills
referred to the judiciary committee for
interim study an executive session
will follow a copy of the interim study
bill has been posted on the main page of
the general court website under the
heading
remote meetings please note that all
votes that are taken during the meeting
shall be done by roll call vote let's
start
by taking a roll call attendance when
each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required
under the right to know law i hope you
all have this memorized but i hope i
never have to read it again
um uh the clerk may call the role
i just lost my well i can call the roll
madam chair if it's okay
please do representative keynes
no she's represent that's
here she's she just needs to unmute um
just as a note everyone
is in control of their mute and unmute
today so um
just make sure that you unmute when your
name is called
representative birch i'm here at home
alone
representative oregon i'm i'm under a
home
home alone in a office in durham
representative woodbury uh i'm here at
home in new boston
uh my wife may come and go out of the
room from time to time but i'm alone at
present
present i'm here in stratham i'm in the
room by myself
but my husband may come in later on
representative di lorenzo you look
unmuted to me
i see your name on the screen i'll come
back
representative burroughs i'm i'm present
and i'm blissfully alone
representative chase i'm present my
sister is here
stevens
where did everyone go well they're there
i've asked representative stevens to
unmute it looks like she might be frozen
though
representative sylvia here the
connection
comes and goes drops regularly i'm here
home alone in
belmont the clerk is here representative
representative janbran
going once more so i can talk
see i sounded like you're here
yes i'm here and i'm buying my lonesome
i'm i'm here in hillsborough alone in a
conference room
representative alexander um i'm here
right now alone but my roommate could be
in and out i'm in goffstown
madam chair i'm here
i'm alone i've lost my video and i'm
going
to leave the call and come back
we can see you that's interesting you
can
yeah live yeah
yeah representative smith would you like
brad to give you a call to see if he can
troubleshoot with you
um well um
yeah see my my screen says
join the new meeting i don't want to do
that let me see wait a minute i think i
let me try this i was afraid to try
anything before
um okay i'm going to be okay now i was
afraid to try anything before you called
me because i thought then you wouldn't
let me um
uh okay i'm nicole
okay and represent whelper i believe
representative lorenzo's yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna go back through the ones that
didn't
because i think we're all here
charlotte are you there yeah i hear you
yes she's moved her hand yes she's here
and she's indicated that she's alone
representative langley is apparently not
here i know
although we have 20 panelists that
should be everybody
it includes the staff though represent
wilbur so we should have probably three
absent
i see you representative stevens is here
i can see her
yes
that might be a photo you know rather
than live
yeah it looks like she was frozen i'm
going to ask brad to give her a call
since she was with us
earlier representative hopper
i haven't seen anything about him a
okay well i guess this is how we're
going to start
um i don't know what to do about
representative stevens where we know
we could see her but whether we call her
here or not here
we're going to try to get some tech help
for her all right thank you
um thank you very much um representative
webber when you agreed
so generously to be the clerk of the
committee
i'm not sure that you counted on
this but then i don't think any of the
before we go to the main subject
of the uh work session today
i do want to tell the committee that
on the list of bills that the governor
has
vetoed one of those bills is house
bill um 1247.
the committee uh supported the bill the
prime sponsor
was uh casey conley um
the bill uh passed the house went to the
senate
the senate made significant changes
with
i think it was representative chanley
but
i'm not sure about that i know it was
representative bradley
and the bill passed the senate it went
to the governor the governor vetoed it
it will be on the calendar for
on september 16th
and um i have asked
um cam uh representative kenny who
wrote the committee report
to represent the committee and um
at the moment i have an inquiry out to
representative conley to see
if he would like to do the pi
even though it is true that the final
bill bears
relation to the bill that passed the
house initially
but i just wanted to alert you all to
that
and before i open
the work session is there anything else
that anyone
wants to share with the committee
not seen anything i'd like to then
1659 this
is a work session it is
not a hearing we will not be taking
testimony from
from anyone um the committee has
uh received in the past
a correspondence email correspondence
from
a number of um
members of the public uh on this bill
and um as i know how conscientious you
all are
i assume you have read all of that
uh so um having opened up the work
session on
house bills 16 59
i remind of the committee
that because this was an
interim study bill there are only two
things we can do the bill
in fact dies when
this session dies
so the bill itself
does not get referred to the next
legislative session it is my hope that
every one of you
will be part of the next legislative
session
and will bring your knowledge back
and i know some of us are in a
actually three of the members of this
committee
in durham um are part of a primary
because there's six
candidates for five positions
um and i don't know about any of the
rest of you
some of you most of you will be in a
general election fight
i'm counting on you all coming back
because we were a very good committee
um but all we can do is we can
recommend the legislation
for further consideration or
not recommend the legislation
for further consideration understanding
that it would not be
this bill um a new bill
would have to be filed um
and i think the freshmen have not uh
have not had that experience and so i
just want to make sure
you're clear that it's not that we're
saying this bill
if we vote to recommend that we're not
saying that this is the bill
that would um appear um
in the next session it will not um
and i would now open um
[Music]
the discussion to um anyone
and could you um
uh miss four i'm sorry i
it just seems that um representative
stevens
is connected if you wanted to just check
in with her quickly
um i think she's connected by audio only
okay so um representative walper would
you like to call her name
representative stevens are you here i am
here can you hear me
we can oh great good morning i'm sorry
to
barge in i've been dealing with
technical
problems trying to be um
i am alone and i am present
and very happy that um speaking to you
thank you well we're happy to hear from
you
and i can't imagine that you're having
technical problems none of the rest of
us
okay now um i'd like to open up
the discussion oh i guess there's one
other thing i should say
and that is that um
i had asked representative chase
to head uh a subcommittee
on this bill when we were still in the
real world
and uh but of course she could not
start that work until we entered the
unreal world that we're in now
nonetheless at my suggestion
not knowing what would happen so that
she would be prepared i asked her
um to make sure people
knew that you know she was interested in
forming
the subcommittee several people did
reach out to her
and that she should do the research that
any chair of a subcommittee should do
so that she would be ready to lead that
subcommittee and she has done that
research and at
whatever time i mean either now or later
i would
um recognize her and i don't think i've
forgotten anything else
but if i have you'll remind me i'm sure
of that
so now um representative stevens do you
want to say something
or not i you'll no i wanna okay
your lights going on and i just didn't
know um
okay okay um and uh
not seeing let's see i go
to participants
and i see representative woodbury has
his hand raised is that
because you would like to speak uh yes
madam chair thank you very much it is i
just have a uh
question and i want to check my memory
because of course we went through this
in detail
my recollection is that in the states
that legislation like this has already
passed
it is not is not commonly used
and i know people have kept statistics
on how
how many people use uh
this this method of ending their lives
but i don't really know
whether to say it's it's there but not
used it's there but it's wildly popular
or somewhere in between i i'm hoping
somebody can
straighten me out um
representative chase would you like to
answer that or would you like me to
um no i i can answer and then you can
jump in
if you'd like thank you very much madam
chair and thank you representative
woodbury for that question
there is um quite a bit of data from
the states that do have the end of life
bill and they put it out every
probably year or every two years
i do have that information if it's
something that the committee
would like to see it breaks categories
down as to age it breaks down as to
disease or diagnosis how many people
actually use the medication how many did
not
how many ended up with a natural death
versus how many
um did decide to to help
their own end so it's very informative
very
thorough i've reached out to most of the
states that do have a end of life bill
and again finding due to covert i didn't
get a lot of
response but the ones that i did like
california
just apologize for being understaffed
i've set up
um a talk with the ethics committee
from the state of virginia i am sorry
i'm so sorry
of vermont which i'm looking forward to
because they'll have a lot more
information so i would like to also
put out there that if there are other
questions like this from the committee
and you'd like to pass them on to me
while i am doing the rest of my research
work on this
i'd be more than happy to to answer
a list of questions versus you know just
trying to do it right now because
it's extremely complex and in depth
does that answer if i could just add to
that are you finished
yes if i could just add to that
um a number of states have been at this
for a long time
a number of states have been at this for
a short period of time
and obviously the longer the experience
um the more instructive uh
is is the the results what
has seems to have been consistent
and actually much to my surprise
particularly i believe in oregon and
in washington is that
the alternative and this is one piece of
a continuum
and the alternative that really
frightens or disturbs
um many of us of
um of actually having um
an assistance in ending one's life
has been used
relatively rarely not just in terms of
the
general public but in terms of those
very people
who have asked
for uh permission
to end their lives
so from that just that pool of the
people who
initiated um action
um the percentage is is very small i
i don't have the numbers in front of me
um and i don't want to misquote so i'm
just saying very small
what has been interesting is that
so many of those patients are in hospice
care
and the hospice professionals report
um in what they believe is a
statistically
significant survey that
those of the pool in hospice
some of those people have requested
permission
um for assisted uh end of the
end of life and some haven't the ones
who
have have ended up
with less depression
more emotional stability more
ability to relate to other people and a
whole list of things
because the professionals say and i
don't know if this is true
that they they have some comfort from
knowing
at some point if they can't
handle it anymore they do have an
alternative
and that alone has
made their end of life
more peaceful and
made them better able for example to
maintain
communication with their family and
loved ones
i would not have expected that and i
found that to be very interesting
um the one other thing that i would like
to say
is that there are so many
of people who say what if
um or is this going to
be is anyone going to be forced into
this or is there going to be community
pressure is there going to be financial
pressure
from families um uh
and uh you know
that one of the things that has become
most clear to me
we need to do in this state
a lot more research and a lot
more
evaluation of how
legislation could be structured
what the intentions of any future
legislation would be
and i i don't think we're there yet but
i don't know representative hargan i see
your hand is raised
yes i was um i was just going to
refer back to the fact that um we had um
we had a very long
amendment which completely replaced the
bill
which was submitted after the uh after
the public hearing so um
so just uh some until we don't have to
send this exact bill we actually have
two different versions of the exact bill
the second one um the second one we
couldn't come to the decision was in
fact uh representative burch's majority
uh report
refers to the fact that like they
weren't sure that we had that the bills
these prime sponsors submitted a
completely revised bill and
we couldn't we felt like we didn't deal
with in the time allotted to us um
i mean i myself was actually the
minority and voted
no in the interim study but um
so we do have those two different
amendments and i'm not sure if anybody
wants to speak to like what the
difference between the two was
i mean i'm not the right person to speak
but the difference in the two was
because i
was supposed to put both of them
personally
representative chase thank you madam
chair
um to answer or to
enlighten on your question
representative horrigan
yes there were two amendments the
original bill that had been put in
by representatives sandler i
she did voice that she wasn't really 100
you know sure about
the language in it and it wasn't exactly
what she wanted so she did hand us a
amendment on march 4th of what
it wasn't an approved amendment at that
point
um with a little bit more
of what she wanted in that bill there
were still when i found
and we did as we talked to people at
that open hearing
there were still a lot of questions and
it really the language isn't exactly
what
um people are asking for or wanting to
have some answers put into it
so as far as what the difference is i'm
not 100
sure what it is but i know that the
prime sponsor was
not in agreement with the original one
that had come out to us
and did put in her second one
um that's all i really have on
that um if i could
ask um our committee
researcher needless to say i don't have
access to the files
um as i recall and i hope somebody will
correct me
that amendment that came in did not come
in
um through legislative services and
therefore
um representative hargan um it was
is that is that your recollection also
because in that case you know we've
never had
the sponsor's next proposal
i'm looking at the file representative
smith and there was
one ols amendment
706h by representative
sandler dated february 20th
thank you um
representative chase and could i remind
you all if you just
you know um go to part
participants and and you can just press
rey's hand and that's how i know who
wants to speak
um representative chase thank you madam
chair
in the um the february 20th
amendment which is 0.706h
whether we have it or not there isn't a
part in here that i found to be
we we have let me back up we know
there's a lot of opposition
from our disability community and
mental health just feeling that
there could be some coercion into
the end of life and not really fully
understanding
what i feel fully understanding exactly
what the language of the
bill is versus what could happen
later um so there is a part in that when
people when we do get it and
i it's on page three and it is
paragraph 2 line 15. it says no
person shall be qualified no person
shall be a qualified patient
under this chapter solely because of age
or disability
and three no person or agency including
a legal guardian or
agent under the durability durable
health care power of attorney shall be
authorized to make a request for
medication
pursuant to this chapter on behalf of a
patient who is not
capable so i find that that clause
that's been put in or those lines
does help really put that together
saying that
no you this people have to be capable
of making this decision themselves so
hopefully taking out a little bit more
of the um the
fear of the coercion and um that
a legal guardian or another agent a
durable help cannot just
say i think it's time that's is
up to the patient and there has to be
all of the other rules followed that i
don't need to get into here
in order to even qualify so i really
liked that part of the bill
i think that's some nice language that's
been put in
that um if another legislation if we
bring this
forth we should uh keep or even add to
if we'd like to but i wanted to bring
that up because i find that to be very
important
with some of the issues that were
brought forth to us
thank you representative birch i noticed
that you've given up on them
wisteria and you now have a fall
background but i still recognize you
and thank you um not sure if that's
spring or fall
but i i just wanted to clarify
in my own mind that ultimately we're not
i don't know how much we're going to
discuss the specifics line by line
of either the original bill or the two
suggested amendments
versus what our chair said earlier
all we're going to do is recommend that
this matter be further studied or
not further studied and i don't think we
necessarily have to go
through a lot of the details
but my recollection is that neither
amendment
has been formally uh put on the table
by uh by anybody on the committee
um and looking at the docket i don't see
that the
march amendment was
moved in any way or put on the table i
just wanted to
make sure that was other people's
understanding
that is how i i
remember
am i missing something
make sure i do now representative welper
can someone help to understand i got it
okay there you go
good i forgot all right so i have to
second what representative byrd said
our task here today is not to get into
the weeds of the
of the bill itself and the value of that
or the
problems with it it's to decide whether
or not we
should recommend future legislation
so this basically is a yes or no
question i personally believe that
there is no acceptable way this bill can
be written and so we should not
clearly there and there's a significant
difference of opinion on that on the
committee but that's my view is no
we're not going to find a way of doing
this i don't know of any law in the
in the world that exists that allows
this that would be acceptable to
a very large cohort in our society
but i think that's where the discussion
should should focus
thank you very much for your wise
comments um representative woodbury
thank you madam chair um i intend to
vote in favor of passing this along for
future consideration but i do it
uh simply because i find it
not compatible with the way i look at
the world to shut off
legitimate inquiry into any subject
but i have some severe reservations with
somewhat somewhat but not completely
echo those of representative wolfer
it's clear that this is a
this is a topic and a subject that has
has received a strong
strong condemnation from a large segment
of the society
and we saw that when we had a hearing in
rep's hall
last winter and we continue to see it in
uh in the emails that we're getting i'm
interested to see that
we don't get very many emails from
proponents of this
we get a few but not very many and
a few minutes ago you confirmed what i
thought was true representative smith or
madam chair
that this isn't terribly popular in the
and therefore i when it comes time to
consider some bill in the future
i have real questions about whether it
makes sense to
move forward on something that is so so
strongly disliked by a pretty decent
segment of the of the of our population
and not very popular where it's uh
where it's in force so i'm going to go
ahead with this
but that's not a suggestion that i would
favor a future bill on the subject i
just i'd have to take a look at it as it
okay um and i don't see
following the the guidance of
representative welper and representative
burch
that this is
pro is not the time to say we like
lines 11 through 16 but we don't like
lines 32 through 34 and it's just
the the question is this something where
we would
we uh we recommend for further
legislation or not um i
would like before we end the discussion
to recognize representative chase
who has done research on behalf of the
committee to see if um
if she has anything that she would like
to
share with us about that research
and then from that point on we can
close the workshop and open up the
executive session
representative chase thank you madam
chair and thank you everyone and i
i want to apologize for i wasn't
actually trying to go line by line it
was just something i found
in my research that looked like it had
been
thought about so um yeah i did
try to do as much as i could
with coveton not being able to have a
subcommittee meeting
i just i found out that end of life
bill of some type of legislation has
been submitted 15 times
between 1992 and 2020.
three of the bills were introduced by
the senate and 12 of them by the house
they all weren't
the same they've been tweaked they've
come in in different ways but it's
something that's that that is like
interest
to the residents of new hampshire
whether it be
for or against whether you have an issue
or not
it's extremely important and one way or
another and i really
want to say that i find
this needs con further consideration
um let me see what else i had done yeah
you know the same i have confirmed that
there is a quite a lot of fear
and misunderstanding of the actual
language of the
bill or the legislation versus personal
beliefs and interpretation of what
the bills that have been brought forth
are trying to accomplish
it does create legitimate questions that
definitely need to be addressed and
required further study
but i do believe in merit that this
does require further consideration and
additional work must be done
to improve the bill and the language
before that any
legislation is brought forth i also just
want to throw in there that
um in over this time there has been a
grassroots organization that has been
formed to try to help or to help educate
the public about the complexities if not
the legislation but by the broader
end of life issues
so this is something that i think is
going to be very important it's going to
be helpful
uh the intention is to dive deeply into
the points
brought forth by both the supporters and
the opposition
including as i said the fear and the
unknown and the unattended inaccurate
readings and information regarding
definitions such as qualification
requesting for disposal of medications
just to name a few
clearly there are a lot a lot of
questions out there and by going through
other um states that again as
as representative or chairwoman smith
said
some of them have been for quite a while
starting with oregon who's been almost
20 years now
with their law and then we have two
states who just
passed their law last year which happens
to be our neighbor one
of uh maine so they're still uh
it's kind of all over the place as far
as the information that we're looking
for and to really dive in
but i do feel that the more we talk and
the more we look at this
and who use the medication who didn't
just
being able to be comfort knowing that
you have the choice to make in this
decision um again i just
find it it merits more
more further consideration
for possible future legislation
thank you madam chair
and i guess my question goes to
representative chase a bit i've read
carefully the emails and letters and
i've also gotten phone calls
as i'm sure most are all of us have and
they've been you know thoughtful
citizens
concerned about this legislation but
what i've heard a lot of
is less about the particulars
of what this legislation is attempting
to cover and not cover
and more the the slippery slope of
well if we do a then b
and c which are really terrible are
going to happen
and i'm wondering if as you did your
research
whether first of all this kind of
slippery slope tended to occur
in other places that you've looked at
in other words how realistic a concern
is that if we spend a lot of time let's
say coming up with
very specific legislation and people are
opposed to it because
not what's in it but what might be in it
two years from now or ten years from now
right
representative chase answer that
question thank you
um yes that's a huge concern
and it has not happened
in any of the states that i have talked
with or have researched on
but it is a concern that's why they've
also have ethics committees put together
to go over these things
that is part of the the um information
that i was saying that
is not it's the difference between fears
and misreading of the actual bill
to what the bill is about the bill is
that is written right now and
legislation that's been through and even
based on oregon which these are you know
gives it
you have to have a diagnosis and a
six-month
uh window of life let's put it that way
so i think a lot of the fear what i was
finding when i talked to different
organizations and i have talked to both
pros and cons
and talking and looking at the research
from other states is the fact that
a lot of the fears coming from the
netherlands and from other
countries which do have euthanasia laws
that um they're creepy to tell you the
truth they are i mean the netherlands
no belgium actually has one for
terminally ill children
at this point so i understand the fear
what um that in the slippery slope
you know i think we can put that with
almost any bill you start something as
well what about this what about that
their oregon actually is the first
state who has put in their it's their
first amendment
that's been put in because the
disability community
was feeling that again they were being
discriminated
some people because they weren't able to
administer the medication themselves
so that has now changed and there's been
amendment put in for that bill
um so
yes it's a fear yes i did not really see
where
it's made any difference in the bills of
the
or the laws of the states that have this
right now but i'm
also still working on that this is a
work in progress like i said i'm going
to be talking with the
vermont uh director of the ethics
committee and these are questions i want
to put out there when i get that
information i would love to share it
that answer thank you
uh thank you now let's see i think
good morning madam chair good morning
uh so first of all i want to start with
a
an objection to all of these zoom type
meetings
as far as uh our constitution part first
uh
article 8 is concerned i i do not find
this to be
a process that is open and transparent
for the citizens contemporaneously
being a a
an actual at the same time kind of
meeting
um this goes on and this is not not a
a knock on the chair um i know that the
chair is as frustrated as
some of us are where you can stick your
hand up and
i was currently i was on my telephone
earlier
and it was cutting in and out so i had
occasional uh
little bits of pieces that i could hear
i
started up my computer and that problem
has gone away
but as we saw in our previous work
sessions
it's really hard to make a point
and counter a point that you might want
to at the same time
and then as things go along you build up
while you're waiting and your hand is up
you you kind of make a little list of
things that points that you wanted to
counter along the way
and it turns into this long filibuster
not not intentional but just by
the way the process works so i just
wanted to
put that objection out for
the purpose of these meetings and i find
it
uh it lacks transparency as to the issue
uh this is my fourth term and i believe
we've probably had
something on these uh these issues each
and every one of them
um end of life is a very
contentious issue just right up there
with abortion
uh startup life if you will and
uh i don't think we're getting anywhere
with this so i would
recommend that we do not recommend
further legislation
and i yield the floor thank you very
much
and representative sylvia in the words
of someone else
i would say i feel your pain i
cannot tell you how much i dislike this
process
um representative mclean
uh thank you manager i i just want to
say
that the reason that i think that this
kind of legislation
is dangerous is because no matter what
the language
and if the language even becomes very
tight
it can love people i think into
a sense of security that hey we've got
this all buttoned up
and then what happens is it tends to
normalize
things and then from there you can
proceed on to other things and
just listening to representative chase
representative chase mata
made a point when she was talking about
the belgian legislation
where he said well that's downright
creepy
and and we wouldn't do that here but
the belgians probably don't think it's
creepy because
i they've maybe gone through this
normalization process and
i really think that's we i don't think
we're ever going to get the language
that is so
tight that it it it kind of carries
through so that's my concern with this
kind of legislation thank you madam
chair
thank you very much uh representative
gordon
thank you madam chair i uh
i think think of it very much the same
way as representative woodbury has and
and that is uh our only decision really
is to
uh make a recommendation that it be
further studied in the
next session so my decision it seems to
me that my decision today is
just whether or not i think we should
today
vote to have this studied in the next
session
but i've listened carefully to
representative chase as well today and i
think she's done a very nice job
uh presenting the case but my my concern
is that
if i vote just to pass it on to the next
session
then it is somewhat of an endorsement
and as i as as has been said this
this bill or a bill of this type has
been brought in
in virtually every session for a very
long time
and there is nothing to prevent someone
from bringing a similar bill
to be studied in the next session
and if my concern is that if i say
yes i want this to be further study i am
endorsing the approach
i'm in effect endorsing this piece of
legislation
or this approach and saying i think this
is what should be studied so i think i'm
going to
end up voting i take the same approach
as
woodbury i i really think things should
be studied
but i don't think it necessarily should
be endorsed and i'm probably going to
vote against it
uh thank you representative hargan
sarah i'm unmuted um i i
i'm if i'm still planning to vote no
this is a perennial issue so i'm sure
we will have bills related to this topic
coming
coming in for year after year until
somebody finally thinks of something
that has consensus i
i think we've made a lot of advances in
hospice and palliative care
but i'm uh not sure whether physician
assisted suicide is a good
is a is a good idea given that we can do
a lot of
wonderful things just with the hospice
hospice care
and also um and also
there's also worried about uh people
also worry about there's often
others also there's also a question of
whether like people severely disabled or
people you know who have terminal
illnesses whether or not their lives
are worth living and so the people who
are living those lives
may feel that they're may feel that life
is worth living but then those around
them they may
may not understand that so i think i'm
very concerned
i usually work very closely with the
disability communities often as often as
i can and they're
they're extremely worried about about
this bill even though
even though many of them tend to be
pro-choice and other related issues some
also find just the final rhythm of
silvia said i the technology
doesn't work for but i think it's
constitutional and even some ways has
some advantages so like
when we get back to in-person meetings
and i'm not going to say that's going to
be uh
the first week in january 2021 i think
we may you know consider changing some
of the ways we do the in-person meetings
too but um
anyway so i'm i'm still bit i still plan
to vote no even though i fully
understand that there will be more bills
and
um i look forward i look forward to uh
seeing those new bills in the areas and
pretty maybe pretty soon we can have
mass hearings and reptal again because
that was uh
definitely a great uh exercise and
participatory participatory democracy
that we had
way back what seems like about 20 years
ago in
january
yes i'm done thank you representative
burroughs
thank you madam chair um i'm gonna vote
yes um
which does not signify that um
i'm in favor of um assisted suicide it
will be a measure of
believing that we need more discussion
and we have for as
madam chair said we have heard from a
lot of people
in the state who um oppose um any type
of legislation of this sort
but i think we need to hear more i think
people in the state and in the
legislature
really need to hear more from families
and individuals who find
themselves in these situations to better
understand it and
that's one reason that i will be voting
yes on this and i'm hoping that we get
to hear from those people
um thank you representative dilorenzo
uh thank you madam here can you hear me
can hear you
yep oh oh great thank you um i'm going
to be voting
no and i have a very strong opposition
mainly because of disparities in um
health care for minorities and poor
people
um and there's been a history of
healthcare disparities amongst african
americans when you go back
to the tuskegee um
syphilis trials on imprisoned men um
there were women who
there was a name dr marion i forget his
last name but he
experimented on african-american woman
and gave them
surgery without um any
anesthetic and i myself
had to go to the emergency room um a
couple of years ago i was having chest
pains
um i went to the emergency room and they
did some tests tommy kept me overnight
and released me the next day
and they gave me a diagnosis of um
indigestion dyspepsia and so i followed
up with my pcp
and went to have a stress test
and i found the stress stress test the
next thing you know i was in a hospital
and it ended up that i had a
um black artery
and i i underwent a
an emergency catheterization and
i'm fine now it was all cleared up with
medication
and so i just feel like
we're not careful enough and we don't
know enough about end of life
to make these decisions and so i'm
totally against this bill
thank you thank you very much um
representative does anyone want to speak
for the first time
if not representative welper i thank you
madam chair
um i bel i believe that we
vote that house bill 1659
be not recommended for future
legislation
thank you very much representative i i
recognize you to speak
the conversations representative keynes
has
and so i'm not going to accept that at
this moment
representative keynes um indicated
that she wanted to speak um and without
having raised her hand but now she has
so representative keynes
thank you madam chair uh i i think we
have to be very careful about the
legislative process
to say nothing about how we decide and
that
it we only go forward when there's a
majority in the public
this country spends millions of dollars
millions on medical procedures and
medical
devices and medical uh
items that only affect
less than 50 or 60 people across the
whole country
and i i don't think it's we should be in
the middle of that to be perfectly
honest with you i'm not even sure we
should be in the middle of any medical
decisions
but i i think it's our a long
you know we're not taking into
consideration the small families that
have this happen to them and and they're
not
even if they all came forward that
wouldn't be a ton of people that came
forward
i i find that most of my uh
most of my uh emails and whatever
came from groups that are affiliated
with churches
that doesn't have to be religion doesn't
have to be it doesn't happen to be
one of my priorities um
and so whatever one believes in their
church that's fine and i hope it brings
them peace and comfort
but it's not for me um
i i think that one of the most poignant
things we got was the
letter from the lady with aoals i mean
she was in her 40s
and she was consigned to only having her
eyes to communicate
yesterday in the boston globe was an
article about
pete freddy's the ice bucket challenge
young man
and what he told his folks
specifically his dad was
that it was like being buried alive
i don't want to be in the position and
obviously neither one of these people
would have been able to take advantage
of this because i don't think they're in
a position to be able to
execute it in themselves they would have
had to depend on someone else and that's
not
allowed but i i think we have to be very
careful about
well it's only a minority it's not the
majority opinion out there in it
look how long it took us how many
sessions it took us to get medical
marijuana passed
it was eons and and that's
not right it isn't we should not be
making medical decisions in the
new hampshire legislature we should be
allowing the professionals to come
forward and listen to what they say
this thought reminds me of washington
right now you know and i
it's not right it's not right in my
opinion
so that's my say and i'm done thank you
madam chair
thank you very much um anyone else want
to speak for the first time
um representative chase actually diane
just raised her hand if you'd like to
call on her
ah i did not see that um
your muted representative
uh wait try again
representative can you speak yes am i
okay now we can hear you
okay um good morning all
i've been listening carefully to this
conversation and i
i was one of the people that um was on
the committee
to help wendy do some some of the work
the preliminary work
and i think you know as we've gone
forward and gotten a lot of
information in the mail from our our
constituents
i've had a reaction to what i've gotten
because i felt
as though all of it almost all of the
letters and all the comments
were inflammatory starting out with
people talking about
this bill as assisted suicide it's not
assisted suicide
it's something very different and i i
think that's
a clarity i think that's a definition
that people use
to inflame the issues so that um
large groups of people are in opposition
to it but more importantly i
i think what sandy was just saying is
really critical
i mean the analysis of the person who
felt like they were buried alive i just
think it's
so poignant we're not talking about this
as being
something that would be administered to
everybody we're talking about
this kind of legislation is perhaps
being an option
and a choice that a person can make at
the end of their life
and i think that's critical i think a
lot of people are making that choice now
and we're just um pretending like
they're not
because there are a lot of people in
hospice that are being heavily
medicated but ultimately the end result
is the same and
i just think it's difficult because we
haven't
had an honest conversation well we've
had conversations and they've been
honest
but they've been so polarized by
political positions and emotions
i'm going to vote forward vote for it to
move forward
and i support continued study and i
understand that we've
we've done it for 12 times in the last
several years but i just think it's an
issue that really needs
further investigation and i think there
needs to be better clarity
in terms of defining uh suicide as
opposed to
comfort measures at the end of life
thank you
thank you very much um representative
chase do you have something to add that
hasn't been said
um i did well i just wanted to say
really quickly that i
found you all know about my daughter
my daughter wouldn't even have qualified
for this once we got you know i really
got looking at it so again i
i do feel that what would like to
find out in the what ifs and who really
would use this
are like als um ms even alzheimer's
is a questionable when you're living
like that in
in i can't breathe yes or you know it's
like drowning
these are just not great ways of living
and if somebody
wanted to make that decision i think
that that's again where we need to
really let this bill be studied
and consider all of these other areas of
illnesses and
as far as i just wanted to touch on the
medical
being able to i understand not getting
involved in the medical issues i've been
fighting that my entire life with my
daughter
and i just don't feel that
because of say the opiate epidemic and
personal
hand with what happened with my daughter
getting too much medication
at times i don't think that is something
that we should just give to the medical
community to do i don't feel that's
right for a doctor just to
say okay i'm going to give you these
pills you can take them when you want i
do
feel legislation does need to be a part
of this
to at least set the guidelines in the
right and wrong
and be able to to decipher suicide
versus
a person deciding to end their life that
fits all the criteria and i am going to
vote
yes that i believe this needs a lot more
study and it is definitely not going
away
thank you very much without objection
i'm going to
close the work session on house bill
1659 and open
the executive session the executive
session has been noticed
which is why we can um
in violation of the way we ordinarily
would like to do this
and i look at representative sylvia's
name um out of respect for his comments
we are going to have an executive
session following immediately
the work session um and
uh opening up the executive session i
first want to ask representative welper
if any member of the committee
has um arrived um
who you do not have listed as presence
for example
did you have representative langley as
president i know manager i did not
but why i have the opportunity to speak
uh it is part of the subcommittee
process that the subcommittee make a
recommendation to the full committee
and so i would like to again move that
we vote yes
i ask you first is there anyone
no who you do not have you now is
everyone who
who is here acknowledged so that they
can vote
yes madam sure we have 18 present too
absent
thank you very much and now i repres
recognize representative welfare for
a motion i move madam chair that the
subcommittee recommend that we not
recognize
the subcommittee no recommended house
bill
1659. committee representative
not the subject all right so i moved
that we we uh vote house bill
1659 not recommended for future action
thank you is there a second to
a second i'll second that um uh
representative lorenzo seconded the
motion the motion before us
is to not recommend
uh 1659 for further
legislation is there any further
discussion
so on house bill 60 1659
to not recommend for future legislation
representative keynes voted no
i'm not sure representative keynes knows
so i think she does she voted no
the motion is not to pass and i am
voting no
against that i want to see it
very nice representative burch no
representative oregon yes
representative altshire no
representative lorenzo yes
i'm confused i'm sorry let me
let me re let me repeat the motion the
motion before us
is to not recommend
um this uh bill for further legislation
if you agree with the motion which is a
negative
motion then you vote yes
in other words that you do not want the
legislation
to be recommended you don't able to be
recommended for further
legislation if you do not agree with
that in other words if you do want
to recommend for further legislation
then you vote no
it is classic legislative jargon where
yes means no
and no means yes everybody clear
okay i believe that the clerk has
recognized you
representative chase no representative
kenny
no representative stevens no
representative harper's not here
representative sylvia
over the objection to the process i vote
yes
no no
the court votes yes representative
gordon
yes representative janbran
come on come on over here
is he still with us he appears to be
with us and he
oh there's some activity
you're unmuted represent january
represented well but let's go back to
representative jan vernon after you
finish
yes yes
representative janmen can you vote
thank you madam chair with one two three
four
five six seven eight in the affirmative
uh thank you very much uh the chair
recognizes uh representative chase for a
motion
emotion that we
give hb 16 59
further consideration
i believe that what you wanted to say is
that you
you recommend this bill for further
legislation
is that what you wanted to say that's
exactly what i thought i was saying
i thought it was what you wanted to say
second representative birch seconds
the motion was made by representative
chase it was second by
re uh representative birch
and the clerk may call the roll
and in this case a yes vote
means yes you would like to recommend
for further legislation
a no vote means you do not want to
recommend for further legislation
representative welcome representative
recommending house bill 1659 for future
legislation representative keynes
yes representative verge
yes representative oregon no
representative woodbury yes
representative all children
representative dilorenzo
no representative burrows
yes representative chase yes
yes representative langley
still objecting to the process no
representative welper votes no
representative gordon
no representative jan brown
no representative mclean
no representative alexander
no madam chair
represent stevens if you could dial star
yes
the vote being 10 in the affirmative aid
in the negative
the motion carries
uh
represent i'm sorry um
miss ford do we um
actually file a committee report or only
the result
of the vote it's not a committee report
that comes out but it is
a statement because it's it won't be
reported to the full house but it is a
statement of the committee
and it can include um everyone's
right position all right representative
chase is the maker of the motion if you
would
draft such a statement and make sure
that the statement includes
not only the uh
the reference to the arguments in
support but also
reference to the arguments that were
against
so that there is a complete um summary
is there any other business to come
before
um not seeing any i hope that i will
see you all um on the
16th um
certainly had hoped we would have a
celebratory
celebratory gathering of the committee
um and uh
that's obviously not going to happen um
again i would like to thank all of you
for um collegial
cooperative civil
um responsible
debate over issues that are
sometimes quite contentious and i could
not have hoped for a better committee
and um it is my understanding that at
least
as of today all of you hope
to be back next
next term that no one has chosen so far
not to run again and
i hope that that continues to be the
case
and wish you all well uh representative
no i guess not oh i'm good i'm good okay
i
know you are i agree okay
um then um the
adjourned